oui les blogueurs et youtuber
tourangeaux sont bien actifs sur la
toile et l'objectif de blogging tour est
bien de mettre en avant leur dynamisme
et leur créativité
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
vraiment beaucoup d'intervenants sur la
toile observe le grain youtuber et on
n'a vraiment pas eu de mal à choisir les
25 vainqueurs qui sont là aujourd'hui il
y en a pas pris simplement à cause du
lieu parce que c'est un petit set 7 ça
mais via vraiment un dynamisme dans tous
les domaines à la fois culturelles des
commodes un faux phare ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses
le salon permettent ainsi une rencontre
non virtuelle pour une fois entre les
blogueurs et leur public
il offre aussi l'occasion de découvrir
effectivement la variété des thématiques
abordées
j'aime bien faire la décoration j'aime
bien faire la cuisine j'aime bien juste
bavarder comme ça raconter ce que j'aime
ce que j'aime pas aussi j'essaye de
partager des choses qui sont abordables
en fait je j'ai envie que tout le monde
puisse se dire ah oui tiens ça coûte pas
cher ah oui tiens c'est pratique et que
la personne est l'astuce parce qu'on n'y
pense pas forcément où on n'a pas le
temps de le dire tu été aperçus que sur
internet l'architecturé tu es toujours
vu comme que je suis une discipline très
sérieuse très très importante chose
qu'elle est mais en fait pour essayer
d'ouvrir sa au grand public et faire
découvrir enfin faire partager ma
passion
j'avais envie de quelque chose de plus
léger plus humoristique et donc
c'est vraiment le l'angle de nombre
d'enfants login tours propose aussi des
moments de réflexion et d'échangés
autour de cette offre digitale qui a
complètement modifié nos façons de nous
informer